[Musique]
le château de bretil ouvre ses portes
aux adeptes des Nimes sanglantes une
murdeur Pary animée par deux comédiens
vous feront vivre dans les années 20
pendant 2hures pour comprendre ce qu'
est arrivé à la comtesse
nunatique petit sorciers vampire et
autres monstres seront attendus à
l'espace Philippe Noiré aux clés
sous-bois pour Halloween les animations
gratuit seront prévu pour toute la
famille au programme maquillage
activités manuell escape game et chasse
aux bonbons et ce n'est pas tout un
spectacle terrifiant et prévu pour
18h30 d'étranges monstres s'installe
dans le parc de France Miniature ils ont
volé les bijoux de la reine alionos de
la citrouille des indices sont
dissimulés dans les monuments et retenu
par ces drôles de créatures en
participant au jeux de piste vous
aiderez la reine à retrouver le voleur
le billet adulte et enfant est à 20
€.